we have the brand new M2 Mac Mini
probably the best bang for the buck
computer out there and we are super
excited to take a look and test this
thing out but first what we are most
curious about is if Apple changed the
cooling system because this has a new M2
Chip in it and of course they're
allowing you to get the M2 Pro and even
the M2 uses 30 percent more power
actually slightly more than that
compared to the original one now with
that Apple has been cheaping out with
ssds so we want to see did Apple lower
the SSD performance just like they did
with the 13 inch MacBook Pro and air
well right now we are gonna find out now
as I'm opening up this thing I have to
let you know that we are doing a
giveaway not only of a new 14-inch M2
Pro MacBook Pro but also a Mac Mini and
all you have to do is one be subscribed
two enable notifications and three
comment down below which you could do on
our previous launch videos all the way
up to February 1st when we we are
announcing the winner and with that we
actually bought 10 Max plus two more
today so we're gonna do a ton of
different testing and comparisons so you
definitely want to be subscribed all
right it's almost off here and one of
the things I'm excited for is the new
Wi-Fi 6E and the updated Bluetooth and I
will be testing that out actually went
out and bought a new router so we can
get the maximum speeds let's get that
cable undone look how tiny that little
motherboard is a part of me still wishes
that they redesigned this and Vadim
what's up look at this no no do you see
that oh I do do you see that we thought
this could happen Apple dropped the
price at least that's a good thing but
we have an empty SSD uh little section
right there that previously did have a
SSD chip in there a little memory chip
uh and that means that most likely the
SSD in here is going to be very slow and
that does make a difference like we
showed you guys but we will test that
out let's go ahead and take this fan off
and to me it looks basically identical
to the previous one which is okay
because the previous M1 Mac Mini didn't
have an issue cooling uh but of course
the M2 uses quite a bit more power now
there is a chance that Apple could be
spinning this fan up higher uh we'll
check that part of it out and on the
right side here you guys see that power
supply it is quite large for the system
it's the same as the old Intel ones that
used a ton of power but if you get the
M2 Pro it actually has has a larger
power supply all right we got that part
of it out and now you can have a closer
look of that memory chip a single one
and that empty slot where Apple used to
put in two and we know now it's not a
part of a memory shortage there's plenty
of chips and they went down in cost by a
lot so pretty much everything looks
identical to the M1 Mac Mini the cooler
looks the same and it just shocks me how
much empty space there is in this system
now let's go ahead and put this back
together because we are going to turn it
on and test out the ssds and maybe a few
other things so we're all set up we're
installing the latest software updates
and one cool thing we just saw on
Twitter is that the M2 Mac Mini was
registered by Apple almost a year ago in
February of 2022 so we talked about the
Mac Mini is going to launch in the March
event last year well it was ready they
registered it but they waited this long
to actually release it for multiple
reasons alright we have black match
magic ready to test but before we do
that if you're a Mac User who does any
sort of work with documents spreadsheets
or slideshows on your Mac our sponsor
software keep has given our viewers 25
off genuine Microsoft software like a
one-time purchase of Microsoft Office
for Mac which includes word excel and
PowerPoint now there are so many fishy
websites out there that could scam you
but software keep is a Microsoft
certified partner who only sells 100
genuine Microsoft software so you don't
have to worry which resulted in software
keep earning over one hundred thousand
five star reviews they also have great
prices on other software including the
most popular antivirus software out
there and their customer service is
phenomenal with 24 7 365 customer
support really get to talk to a real
person instead of a robot so if you have
any questions they'll be glad to help so
buy a Microsoft Office for Mac or
anything else that you need today and
save 25 off their already great prices
by using the link in the description in
the coupon code
mtyt25 so here you can see that we have
the base model Mac Mini for 599 or 4.99
if you're a student 256 gig of RAM we
don't have very much stuff on here which
will help with this test latest software
let's go ahead and check out the
Blackmagic speed so right away there you
guys are seeing that we're getting 16
14. oh my gosh the read speed is 1547
usually it's a little bit higher on the
first run right there you can see just
like the M2 MacBook Pro meant to air it
actually settles down at 1400 on the
right speed that is actually slower than
the 2018
Mac Mini with Intel that Intel model is
almost twice as fast in terms of write
speed and the 2018 Intel is 70 faster in
terms of read speed but how does it
compare to the previous M1 Mac Mini well
in terms of the write speed the M1 is 60
faster and in terms of read speed the M1
version is about 90 percent faster are
almost twice as fast so what do these
performance numbers mean for the real
world well let you guys know here in
just a sec and the performance
differences but at least I want to say
that I'm glad the app will lowered the
price by a hundred dollars since they're
making this a lot slower but with that
I'm also very nervous about the 512
gigabyte model which it costs 200 more
now we actually bought four total Mac
minis with a variety of specs both a
couple of M2 models and a couple M2 Pros
so we'll test out the 512 and hopefully
that version is not as slow as this one
is make sure you guys are subscribed if
you guys want to see that now with
performance this bad if you're somebody
that just does web browsing checking
emails you will be just fine as long as
you don't open up a crazy amount of tabs
but if you're somebody that's productive
with their Mac which you most likely are
if you're watching this channel we broke
with the M2 MacBook Pros that we saw a
big difference in performance even if
you don't do anything too extreme now we
did have a lot of haters that were
saying it doesn't matter but some of
them actually changed their minds later
when they actually use the system for
themselves and said it does make a big
difference for example just transferring
a 42 gigabyte folder we saw a massive
difference in performance 23 seconds
compared to 2 minutes and 17 seconds and
yes the empty Mac Pro's ssds perform
exactly like this to M2 Mac Mini now why
is it such a huge difference even though
the speed's about half well the way ssds
work is you have caching so not only do
you have the slower speeds but after
just a small file transfer the speeds
slow down dramatically and we have a
massive difference in performance and
then if you're doing video editing with
just 10 chrome tabs open and then if
you're doing Simple video editing with
just 10 tabs open the base model was
actually twice as slow as the 512
because Apple slowed it down and moved
on those chips and even the M1 MacBook
Air Base model was quite a bit faster
than the new M2 setup and that's
something that you would not expect with
a brand new machine coming out years
later and the same thing goes for those
of you guys that work with photos having
both 8 gigs of RAM just the difference
in SSD made the system almost twice as
fast when you're exporting and who
doesn't have web browsing tabs open and
not only that it gets way worse if
you're running more things like a couple
different programs and even the whole
system will get laggy because they do
use swap memory and the SSD is so much
slower that it slows your whole system
down now we have very detailed videos
comparing 8 gig or 16 comparing 256
versus 512 with only sses being
different so if you're considering
buying a base model or upgrading to 512
check out those videos because there's a
lot of great info and a lot more tests
but with that said with all the
knowledge that we have testing the M2
chips with these SSD slow down issues
and cost cutting I will just say that if
you're watching our Channel you should
definitely spend extra money and get a
good SSD we'll test out the 512 is twice
as fast so we'll see that here very soon
but in general with apple silicon the
way the architecture and the unified
memory is designed you need to have fast
SSD so it's very disappointing to see
apple cutting costs like this in their
production the chips are plentiful
they're cheap and honestly I wish that
they kept the price the same but gave us
twice as fast ssds instead of now
lowering it by 100 bucks but then you
need to spend another 200 more to get
fast ssds because not everybody needs to
have 512 we use external storage here's
our recommended SSD we'll link it down
in the description as well and with that
you have a lot more flexibility you can
use the multiple systems so we would buy
a base model but now we can't and we
would not suggest buying a base model
stop don't buy this one if you watch
Tech videos you do productivity it's
well worth it to have the full
performance the way the M2 Chip was
meant to be run so once again comment
down below make sure you subscribe and
have a notifications enabled so you're
entered to win watch the previous videos
back to the launch comment on those and
the new ones that we're gonna make with
these new Macs and comments so you guys
have the best chance to win either 14
inch MacBook Pro or a Mac Mini and we'll
reveal the winner on February 1st check
out those videos right there comparing
the ssds and their Ram click above to
subscribe to some Max and I'll see you
in the next one
foreign